the role of Metropolitan Police
Commissioner is the biggest in UK
policing but what does the job involve
the commissioner is chosen by the Home
Secretary but the views of the mayor of
London have to be taken into account the
commissioner's main job is to run the
police in London but it comes with some
national responsibilities too the
commissioner commands nearly 34 000
police officers at around 10 000 support
staff it takes a lot of people and
resources to try to keep the capitals
nine million people safe
the Mets National role includes
counter-terrorism guarding the royal
family Parliament and Senior politicians
and protecting foreign embassies
Kitchener and the Met are independent of
government but a tricky part of the job
is managing the tensions and
expectations of two bosses who may be
from opposing political parties
the last commissioner Dane Cressida dick
resigned after clashing with Labor's
London mayor Sadiq Khan though she
appeared to have the support of the Tory
Home Secretary putty Patel
public trust and confidence in the Met
police fell after a wave of scandals
during Crescent addict's time as
commissioner they included the abduction
rape and murder of marketing executive
Sarah everard by off-duty PC Wayne
cousins the taking and sharing of
photographs of two murdered Sisters by
police guarding their bodies
the racist and misogynist text message
sharing by officers at Charing Cross
police station
the forces handling of lockdown parties
in Downing Street
and the strip searching of a young black
schoolgirl in East London
[Music]
replacing Dame Cressida dick is Sir Mark
Rowley
promise more trust less crime and high
standards I will to the best of my skill
and knowledge discharge all duties
thereof faithfully and according to the
law he was an assistant commissioner at
the Met and head of counter-terror
policing for the UK between 2014 and
2018 he was knighted for his services to
policing and was also awarded the
Queen's police medal
before that he was the chief Constable
of Surrey and spent five years leading
the high-profile investigation into the
murder of Millie Dowler
he admits some friends thought he was
crazy to take on his new job samark will
be under No Illusion about the
improvements he's expected to make in
the Mets culture and performance and his
political Masters will want results soon